>>Narrator: It's the end of the
regular school day for Justin Marks.
>>Did you turn in that assignment?
>>Yeah.
>>Me too.
>>Narrator: And it's
only twelve o'clock.
A senior at San Francisco's School
of the Arts, Marks has one hour
to grab lunch and drive from his high
school campus to a downtown office,
where he'll spend the rest of his
learning day as an intern at one
of the city's top architectural
firms.
>>We did a walkthrough at the
base of clock tower to find out--
>>Justin: I'm pretty much
an assistant architect,
like I get to see everything
an architect has to do,
has to go through, has to
deal with, and it's school.
I go there and I just learn tons.
>>Narrator: Marks works
here twice a week
and spends his other
three weekday afternoons
at the Build San Francisco
Institute, a small school created
by the Architectural Foundation
of San Francisco, in partnership
with the city's unified
school district.
>>Frank: What we've targeted are
students who have not done well
in school and we want them to finish
and we want to give them a reason
for finishing, and hopefully
along the way, for them to see
that there's career opportunities
for them beyond getting
their high school diploma.
>>Narrator: Students from high
schools all over the city arrive
at this Market Street office space
and spend the next three
hours immersed in projects
that satisfy core curriculum
objectives
in integrated studies,
fine arts and math.
>>Nine.
>>Diameter, nine in diameter.
>>Narrator: And there's a night and
day difference between what goes
on here and what usually goes on
at the schools they come from.
>>Will: In a traditional math
class, they begin with a textbook.
They have the students open
to the page for the day.
They might be working on something
like perimeter or area or volume.
If I were the teacher, I would
stand in front of the class,
teach all thirty students
this one concept at one time.
I'd write things on the board,
work out a few sample problems
and then send the students home,
and they would either get it
or not, and then they'd move on.
Here, we do design challenges
where students actually apply the
mathematics in a real world problem.
This particular problem was to design
a million dollar condominium using
San Francisco housing costs,
which are eight hundred
dollars a square foot.
From there, it becomes a
very challenging process
to develop a three
bedroom condominium.
Working with the mathematics all the
way, scale, proportion, area, volume,
applying the knowledge rather than
just working it through once on a set
of problems, and I think
that's the road to mastery.
>>Casey: We're gonna
have to fix this somehow.
We're probably gonna have to take
this wall out and do it again.
>>Will: And there's no
room for C plus work.
If you're going to build a building
in San Francisco, everything has
to be pretty tight,
so they understand
that we don't accept second
rate work here, because we know
that they're not going to be
doing that in the real world,
so why start them with the
sense that they can get by?
>>It has to be done, why?
>>Because people are
gonna live there.
>>Narrator: Fowler and teacher
Casey Brennan carefully review the
curriculum standards for the math and
fine arts courses they will teach.
>>Casey: Students analyze issues of
international trade and explain--
>>Narrator: Then they design
projects that engage their students
in mastering the subject.
>>Casey: You don't have
to scrap the design,
'cause the design is beautiful, but
what you need to do is rescale it
so that it stays within
those parameters.
>>I don't stand in front
of the kids and say,
"This is how you're
going to learn today."
I mean, they do have
an agenda every day.
They know what the objectives are,
but they do the investigating.
I give them the materials,
and they do the research.
They do the uncovering
of their own curriculum,
and the kids take ownership
of their education
and it becomes more
meaningful to them.
>>Narrator: Before any
major project is undertaken,
students complete small projects
like a PowerPoint presentation
on various architectural styles.
>>Mikalynn: You get to
learn about architecture.
You get to learn like more sharpen
up your skills on like algebra,
you know, 'cause like I'm in geometry
now, so like you can forget some
of those little things,
so it helps you
like remember and like keep ahead.
>>Narrator: For their
second major project,
students had to create
a performance space
on a three thousand square foot lot.
>>Casey: So first they
sketch out a blueprint.
From that, based on their
design and the specs,
they take it to Autodesk Revit.
>>Student: This is what my
model looks like when it's
in three D. I have a fireman's
pole in case kids wanna slide down.
>>Casey: It's incredible
design software.
They're able to unfold
their blueprint
into a three dimensional object
that meets all the
specifications of their design.
>>Mikalynn: So right here is where
I did my internet cafe and I decided
to make half of it a sunroom.
So since the sun moves
in a southward direction,
so I decided to put it there
so that there would be more
sunlight during most of the day.
>>Where was your plumbing setup?
>>Casey: I mean, technically,
they could take a design
that they've created and print it out
and actually present
it to a developer.
>>The first step is to
sketch everything out.
>>Narrator: Brennan grades students
on a rubric that includes design,
creativity, presentation
skills and peer review,
and she makes the grading
process transparent.
>>Casey: Kids should know
what they're being graded on.
Kids should know from the very
beginning what the objectives are
and what the expectation are.
Those should be clearly
communicated and understood.
And after that if, you know, it's
done right, then students can say,
"Okay, these are all of the
areas in which I succeeded
or I need improvement," and
that should be a no brainer.
>>Narrator: Seniors at the institute
took part in a public art project,
installing ceramic tiles
depicting historic vessels as part
of a peer restoration project
for the port of San Francisco.
>>Justin: This model I made in
Three D Studio Max and basically,
it's just a little
diagram of the peer.
I showed it to the Port of San
Francisco, they really liked it,
and it turns out that they kinda use
railings that look kinda like this.
>>Narrator: Marks acted as project
manager for the art project.
He sees a vast difference between
learning here and what goes
on in the school he
comes from each day.
>>Justin: Difference is, we all
sit there and the work you have
to do is just in a textbook.
You're not allowed to get up.
You're not free, you're just stuck
there in your uncomfortable desk.
Here, everybody has more
of a positive attitude.
Everybody works together,
pretty much.
>>The earlier design had a
very clear pattern system.
>>Narrator: Twice a week, seniors
spend the afternoon in internships
at major architectural
firms in the city.
>>Man: We have, you know, all
these digital photographs,
so we can verify our drawing and
actually fill in the missing parts--
>>Justin: It definitely
gives you a motivation.
You're doing something different.
It just gives you a
positive effect really,
just doing something that you enjoy.
>>Narrator: Architect Richard Hannum
created the internship program
that became the Build
San Francisco Institute.
He saw the value of
working outside the system
when he became disenchanted
with his own son's public high
school experience.
>>Richard: One Friday, I went
into my son's school and pointed
out that he wouldn't be there on
Monday, and after a few moments,
they realized that I meant not
just Monday, but any Monday
and that was it, and we walked out.
And I started homeschooling James,
my wife and I decided to do that,
and we didn't really
actually know what that meant.
What we found, what we discovered
was as soon as we were away
from the system, as it
was then postulated,
we found all these extremely
interesting, highly educated people
with very creative ideas about
education, with no limitations.
>>Man: Right now, we have
this module here, for example,
and this is a balcony
and this is a window.
>>Richard: We created our own school.
We have several students that we
simply took out of other places
and had come to our
office and it's a school.
>>Narrator: Hannum's
mentoring concept,
with the school district's
backing, has created a model
for other PBL initiatives that could
dramatically change the way young
people learn.
>>Richard: If you find
the current situation
to be unacceptable intellectually,
with what we're doing with children
as a nation, then you have
to actively make change.
And to have found something that has
the level of impact that this has
on children, that's really
so easy to do, is fantastic.
>>Mark where it's going to be.
>>Will: We know this works first
by the reaction from the students.
We get feedback from the
mentors on the growth
that they see the students working
in their firms, and we're starting
to get feedback from test scores.
This is only our second year,
but we're starting to see
that the students are having a
higher success rate in high school,
because they go back to
their high schools energized.
>>Richard: Every time we start a
session, I get frustrated because,
you know, they're just
not gonna make it
and this group's different
than the last group.
And for me, my moment is six
weeks in, when all of a sudden,
they gel up again and off they go.
And it's like another group of
great kids who are no longer going
to see education the same way again.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to Edutopia.org